and II why did people agree that
Einstein had taken a vital step for what
were the what was the observational
support behind this stuff and in
particular I'm thinking about the solar
eclipse experiments well it's an
interesting thing that Einstein himself
as as Steve mentioned a few minutes ago
had some data that he was studying and
one of them was the fact that Mercury's
orbit didn't do exactly what Newton said
it was would do and it was a very tiny
discrepancy and Einstein when he wrote
down his general field equation found
that explained this very tiny
discrepancy and in his own notes he says
that he knew that that was the moment at
which he knew he said something inside
me snapped that was the moment in which
he knew he had it he'd solved this great
problem but nobody bought it because
what a crazy thing to do to introduce a
revolutionize our idea of space and time
say that space is curved and so on just
because some french astronomer or a
hundred years ago his experiments didn't
match up to Newton so nobody bought it
when you explain something that has
already happened it's not convincing yes
Einstein then made a prediction and his
prediction would be its star light would
be bent by the Sun its star light passed
by the Sun it would actually be bent and
that made a prediction about what would
be seen for stars passing near the Sun
during during a total eclipse and that
prediction was verified I think it was
almost five years after Einstein wrote
down his equation and he became an
overnight celebrity yeah so we have a
little picture just emphasizing what you
described so you can speak to it if
you'd like so you see that
two images of the star one coming from
the fact that the trajectory of the
light ray is bent as it passes by the
Sun shifting its apparent position the
sky and indeed as you mentioned Einstein
calculated the angle between those two
and the observations confirmed it and
that was convincing I think the reason
that the fact that Einstein explains
something that was already known was
less convincing than the prediction of
something new was the natural tendency
of people was not to trust the theorist
that is they suspect that if you have a
known fact the theorists will be able to
[ __ ] his theory to get it into
agreement if you know anything about the
way Einstein developed general
relativity that's not true he did not
design his theory to explain that extra
little motion of mercury he used that
motion to test his theory in fact in
earlier versions he had gotten the wrong
result and therefore he knew that those
earlier versions weren't any good and on
the other hand you really shouldn't
trust the experimentalist yes the
experimentalist knows the theory yeah
and it's likely to [ __ ] his
experimental data to get the right
result in fact many people have accused
the experiment the astronomers of 1919
who observed the Eclipse of having they
kept finding errors until they got a
result in agreement with Einstein's
theory yeah they were potentially
throwing out photographic plates that
they claimed were obscured by the bad
weather and they happened to be the ones
that didn't quite agree with the
prediction but since then there's been
many other experiments oh they always
trust with it yeah
you